vous avez cliqué une fois de plus avait
envie de faire peur et alors c'est parti
on est là pour ça on gagne plus de
cadeaux place de halle est saisi par mon
gars là je sais pas ce qui nous attend
mais il a la mine voulue par les
hérétiques parfait c'est là qu'ils
détiennent line mais c'est parfait
j'allais j'allais dire j'allais vous
diront il aimait à dire ça je vais vous
dire et mais il faudrait qu'on trouve
cette mine et ses montagnes où elle est
censée être babylone ou presque s'est
débrouillé babylone à spala pas pour
autant pour moi c'est parfait je rêvais
tout mais cette mine est de rejoindre
les gens qui ont tué ma femme qui donc
vont peut-être me sauver aussi quoi que
j'ai eu mal à tancer cause d'ailleurs la
cactus d'accord pour faire gaffe aux
cactus ça marche ça me va parce que je
me batte du coup non c'est bon j'ai pas
assez mal les coins de bourdes et attend
le détail du cactus abusé quand même une
feuille machja ma plus grande bien aimé
ma compagne intime la plus fidèle au
[ __ ] je peux sa ronde mais c'est très
très long moi j'ai juste envie de
rejoindre linda hains ou linde spa linda
céline oui sa nouvelle maison
on peut stocker quelque chose vous
pensez à bas on peut sauter par mais on
peut s'infiltrer chez cette personne
apparemment des mythes
mon patron c'était pas fort que je le
trouve pour des stades jessica s'est
pendu raquettes tous d'accord très vite
toi d'accord était toujours là tu aimais
taukafa djédjé s'est pendu sa d'accord
annoncés pour lui c'est la vie il parle
de la vision qu'il avait de l'inp en dur
à chier pas [ __ ] j'ai du mal à suivre
bordel j'ai du mal à suivre
en fait j'ai tellement peur tellement
stress dans ce jeu dans ce jeu que j'ai
du mal à me souvenir de l'histoire des
prénoms des trucs c'est oh oh c'est
vraiment pas cool ça sent pas cool ça
casey qui bouge tous le plaisir à
personne
j'espère que ce soit verrouillé pour une
fois tu vois j'espère vraiment que cette
[ __ ] de porte se verrouille et c'est
pas le cas on est mal non des bugs comme
ça c'est pas beau ça on pas sympa à
c'est un peu ouvert il y avait nombre il
y avait nombre je te jure j'ai vu non je
vous dirai pas pourquoi mais j'ai vu une
ombre et ça ça me scandalise légèrement
c'est quoi ça ah c'est un pan du 11e au
pan du kayak au clair avec la claque est
le [ __ ] mais que j'aime pas quand la
cavale fait cet effet à y avait ce jour
là vers la porte j'ai cru voir un truc
pas ces mecs je deviens parano salaires
par ado on n'apprécie pas personne ok
avec toi on continue bloqué est bloqué
tania comme une salle de cours là oriane
milliers note
la majorité du film et le truc du pendu
avec la caméra s'est jouée au moitié
doit être quelque part ah ok c'est un
garçon s'en remettre sur un projecteur
hockey que l'hymne pourrait trouver du
coup si je mets ça là dessus hop voilà
on aime faire partie une arabe c'est la
suite nrj avait une fois le deuxième à
aucun autre but maintenir est d'accord
décalé et très bien on va chercher un
deuxième truc je me suis décidé
et maintenant il faut avancer et ça va
compléter les lettres impardonnable
enfin guy benoit d'accord mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour qu'elles se tue en
fait c'est qu'elle est qu aller jusqu'à
les le bordel quel est le fuck faut que
j'aille ou là bas bon attention non pas
il ya une l'autre côté du couloir à van
la parra ou là bas non des mythes
ah ok une belle porte on est bien des
casiers et une sauvegarde ça me fait pas
plaisir sa caisse est à nous oh il ya un
truc est apparu
yanon viennent on la voyait de foot
qu'est ce que c'est que je ne peux plus
je peux même pas bander allez allez
allez va t'en va t'en
je peux pas aller paître avec ces tombes
de merde là maudit soit tu as là y'a une
salle
ok fallait que j'aille parle des métaux
ah oui ok j'ai compris j'y vais comme ça
je peux pas y aller oh [ __ ] faut que
faut que je mette un truc ok oui et je
veux pas que mon fils revienne il m'a
fait peur
dgo ok on est dans des dents et bien on
est bien bien d'un jamais ici mais
quelle créature c'est à ces amputations
riksdag quelque chose c'est quoi ce
bordel mais clairement j'étais déjà ici
mais mec t'es en train de perdre la tête
tout simplement
teint comme sa part en steaks
un bon le mec devient complètement fou
il vient barrer mon gars vient
complètement barré ok donc je rappelle
qu'on est en train de rejoindre les
mines et de rejoindre notre go bien sur
la corniche huacho là c'est là-haut faut
qu'on aille dans les maisons qui elles
avouent penser
ouais je pense [ __ ] j'ai hâte d'y
aller quoi de découvrir la suite là et
de retrouver ma femme et voir ce qu'elle
est devenue sur le bébé il va il va être
ça va être un gros prématuré ça va être
un démonte c'est quand même et c'est
jamais très bon ok c'est pas trop loin
mais il regarde pas en bas regarde tout
droit voilà c'est la base juste là bas
on y est presque on voit alors ça si ça
craque on est vraiment en paix elle
avait un train avant [ __ ] qu'est
hu à tous les insectes
what ok allez il est en tout cas dur à
les abeilles de merde c'est frustrant on
sera même pas ce que l'heureuse vidéo
qui est en train de prendre c'était
l'ami non loin j'aurais dû la file mais
[ __ ] à les abeilles [ __ ] l ont pas
aimé mon blog
elles m'ont pas laissé bloguer
a maintenant fait jeu produit par les
pieds et j'ai plus ma caméra elle est
devant moi
[Applaudissements]
je peux descendre peut-être ou pas je me
balance six lots j'ai fait tellement de
bruit
le chef de la secte place note paul le
poulpe tu es quoi alléger ma caméra suit
ma caméra ça va oh [ __ ] on dirait que
je vais faire mes tours on dirait bien
tu as raison brasparts un clairement on
se balade up petit parcours on est bien
[Applaudissements]
why not
prend la 7 l'a26 bénédiction pour un
malade et a essayé de partir et je les
briser ne répétez pas ses erreurs et ne
commettait pas ses péchés ok d'accord
mais à un moment je vais faire comme lui
je vais me marrer quelle est la branche
la branche la manche aller à les
personnes derrière on est bien le mec
arraché sur le porche à ce retour dans
l'élite très très chaud allez on est
bien on y croit on va rejoindre la mine
on va être sauvée par nos poteaux de la
mine qui ont sauvé notre femme avant
nous c'est des gens bien sais pas
pourquoi ils habitent aussi proche de
deux sets secs mais l'ont sauvé allez
[ __ ] j'ai pas vu j'ai pas vu qu'il
s'est passé comment ça mon jeu j'aime
pas compris pourquoi il a dit oh mon
dieu je m'embrouille un mec là qui me
suit qui se passe là ça pue le skimmer
ça bon il faut préparer d'ici de partir
tu aimais fois ils sont tous malades ici
que dieu les bénisse
ces gens pourris c'est avant qu'il soit
assassiné [ __ ] on prend un autre
chemin qui est le chemin des cascadeurs
et la [ __ ] on descend trop là ce qu'on
manque de foi qu'on descende alors why
not
et je parle pas du maître de la secte
est maire note note c'est hyper drôle
bienvenue dans ce lieu de guérison
spirituelle vous avez peur vous avez
peur et vous êtes malade comme vous
devriez l'être vous est remplie dont
vous avez raison de l'approché [ __ ] la
mecque au mais il va me défoncer lui
il mange un mec là non temps des rigolos
de ouf
incroyable elle va se déclarent contre
moi les partenaires
au méchant femmes il va falloir way à
mes [ __ ] et céder les pros de ouf en
fait ok faut que j'aie par la barre donc
je passe à côté
je les ignore oh là lâche au milieu des
tarés mon gars oh il avait une balle
trop vite à pois mais je suis content
mapala sépare la hausse à escalader très
vite la loto de beaufitude jugulaire c
ou c ou c ou la vidéo elle s'est
déclenchée à quel moment je tomberais
bontempi j'écoutais le rec est un genre
bogey j'ai pas réussi à retrouver
l'endroit fait chier je fais quoi là une
voiture la semaine c'est carrément un
cul de sac c'est en fait à mais c'est la
[ __ ] il y avait un mur au caire au
delà de la paire de couilles mais il ya
beaucoup de sens d'ailleurs pas le
premier à m'en faire part la petite
corniche à l'on peut le faire
you can do it is he is it ensuite ça y
est
[Applaudissements]
oh là là là il ya des remakes de khalid
bonne mine est question d'être l'une est
le mec dans d'autres laissent coi
laissez moi nous savons trop c'est quoi
ça mais c'est le mec et sur son gros
truc
[Musique]
pas par là par là par la pas par là pas
par l'apa par l'apa par là du tout lâché
baiser bon je me soignais
faut que j'aille parrot faut que j'aille
de la brigue un ça c'est sûr ok go tell
n'en soit 90 des cas les coûts dit me
lance alors mal furent net grimper
traces tu dégages
et voilà du coup on est perdus ne seront
pas là là là j'ai pas pu aller moi de
phoques et des hitman devant le casier
mon gars bon bah sortons vas-y sortons
jeff je te suis dsl et vous lie à un pc
valeo opère poker et j'ai fait sortir
mademoiselle grilles de la classe
ducasse musique aujourd'hui afin d'avoir
une figuration avec quelle paire l'unef
s'inquiète du fait qu'elle soit un peu
trop sensible pour son propre bien haut
et des [ __ ] de mails j'ai ce qui a
greffé trip ok je sais vous avez
rencontré son père 50 personnalités ce
qui est arrivé à sa mère est une vache
la tragédie que dieu ait son âme quoi
qu'il en soit le personnel pour ce que
je ne serai pas une bonne idée de
laisser dsk participé à l'excursion à l'
usine du de piano je suis d'accord avec
lui elle présente car ici qu'un enfant
pris à fuguer
en plus de ça la ceinture de son père
sur la fédé permission est gênant tant
il est évident qu'elle la falsifier j'ai
donc besoin de l'interruption pour ce
point de cette autorisation de la
placeront études à biotech ce jour-là en
la pauvre ok donc elle rate une bonne
sortie scolaire a cool très bien voilà
qui est encore un endroit ça fait
longtemps que pas trouvé de piles il
trouver une pile à les toilettes les
facs king iii relate
opta juillet l'avoir inscrit 28 je me
suis dit ils n'auraient pas osé ils ont
quand même pas osé là ils n'ont pas osé
c'est bien bon ça nous avance pas sur la
trajectoire
moi j'écris en vidéo ça tarde dès que je
prends une vidéo qu'on est dans cet
endroit
et ça marche pas c'est bizarre quand
même si j'avais un toi tu vas pas manger
au [ __ ] je pars pas je suis là et sa
kippa
[Applaudissements]
olala au [ __ ] je joue là d'accord on
repasse dans l'état mais les transitions
elles sont incroyables monga aulas va
donc jesse s'est suicidé elle s'est
pendue on a vu qu'elle a été et est
souvent d'une le haut mais rld
quand on a chip
que dieu son prophète ne soigner j'ai
souri ou sa bouche il est le messie cas
le rendu n'est pas content attention tu
m'as tu en profites sa renaissance
ouais d'alors le mettre sur cette croix
va chercher moi t'aimer tour est alors
sur cette colline
les uns des secrets il m'a tuer comme un
nouveau né
il nous donnera son évangile et paroles
sacrées de son enseignement il sera
cloué à la croix et mourra il entend des
rires mais il a réussi citera dans une
chaire plus parfaite et nous mangerons
sait faire dans la sainte communion et
seront tirés de nos péchés physique et
nous hériterons s'était brisée d'accord
d'accord mais tu croise les doigts nous
avons tout préparé
tout est prêt pour toi quoi nous nous
faites pas ça
où est on est moche et tu es censé avoir
un évangile à partager pour nous guider
d'entre eux saluent après la fin à mes
proches il avait jeté ses conseils
souffert au repas 30 ans eh bien mon
vieux nick je crois que nous ferions
mieux de planter ses clous a donné à
donner
hier
ouais c'est nick deux mois ça c'est une
caméra
ouais on enregistre bien entendu comment
pouvais je ne pas le voir un christ
moderne utiliserait une caméra livre
voici notre évangile non comment ai-je
pu ne pas le savoir
non c'est vrai qu'ils parlent moi
d'avoir titouan il n'y a aucune
souffrance que je ne mérite pas je suis
un verre une version payante une minute
doit se doit étudier ses enseignements
lente l'autre clou et accrocheur
[Musique]
le rex complètement barré mondiale
jamais conçu que je fasse une [ __ ] tu
crois qu'on ce que je fasse
bernheim
oh non
oh non non non ça tape ma main et je
vais mettre un bandage et ça ira mieux
t'inquiète pas regarde mais et fatbardha
ch essayez vous avez besoin de bandage
mais j'en ai pas faut que je trouve
il faut que je trouve un bandage h est
obligé d'aller à gauche super bon il
faut un bandage la [ __ ] ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas lutter de
bandages
one shot
j'ai plus ma caméra j'ai plus rien
vas-y impotente et direction et ben
voilà
[Applaudissements]
la la la elle saute un [ __ ] mais non
non vraiment j'ai trouvé un bandage sous
merde faut soit un bandage
il faut que tu sois un bandage excusez
moi est ce que quelqu'un vend un bandage
contre 3
alors chassé n'ont jamais trouvé bandage
j'étais prêt à me bander [ __ ] rien à
la cvo journée à hiesse j'en avais
trouvé un autre temps faut que je me
barre parce que je sais pas si à part
mais qui est en train de me suivre je le
mette la paix permet à cet arbre ça va
aller ça va aller mieux voilà on est
bien on est bien ça fait le taff un
petit bandage ça guérit tout seul après
ok maintenant je sais où je dois aller
[ __ ] je m'obstine à essayer de choper
le un bandage qui était à droite je vous
montre unique et eva un bandage qui
était juste ici lalancette tente là mais
à lui qui m'a empêché de le prendre donc
c'était infernal à lons casse allez go
on se casse d'ici mec
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] j'ai hâte qu'on trouve famé et
les autres parce que le mec aille se
disaient oui ce qu'il est rip les gars
oulhaj pas bien là où là je vois bien
aller allez courage mais courage ti
bientôt au [ __ ]
non un choix qui m'a vu un
épatant nous le bâtard ben oui je passe
par là va faire le tour à ok mais tu
m'as fait pas un petit qu on merde
ah ben là je crois que s'arrête la fin
base il faut aller par là c'est sûr
pas sympa pas sympa
à
bon faut aller par là ok c'est bon y
avait une pile je sais je sors l'a tous
vu j'ai pas pu l'apprendre désolé
alévêque me mettais trop la pression
hommes et non mais [ __ ] c'est pas
possible ça à part la hockey tels
rejoint les grosses stars disant que
nous aide mais jamais une canyoning
l'assemblée
[Musique]
je suis pas remonter jamais
je pense qu'il m'a vu en moi bonfol
dentaire hockey s'est passé tellement
voici flèche aux larmes
quoi qu'est pas ça
donc là je pense qu'il va falloir à
peine atterri dans l'eau il faut que
j'aille direct dessous en fait je pense
[Applaudissements]
voilà j'espère tenir assez longtemps
pour être très franc
tiens
non non gaston petit j'ai pu faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ok
[Applaudissements]
temps comme c'était chaud mon gars alors
ok maison blanche chameyrat
quelques années avant pour moi c'est au
[ __ ] encore une de ses toiles sont
légendaires ok je crois que dans cette
culture là vraiment qu'est ce qui se
passe là bas mais que tu as des bonne
vision de l'époque clairement au
substrat sa part la nappe à une pile par
là éventuellement une petite fille gâtée
princeton s'est pas là c'est là bas
ouais c'est un téléphone au [ __ ] et ça
m'a fait peur là c'est juste cette vague
là que cela se passe bon
waouh
quant aux noms qu le chemin c'est quoi
je reviens la page vers le début ou
quelles zones safe web c'était cosmos
mon gars là [ __ ] faut que je retourne
voir téléphone mec c'est par là c'est
par la pierre sans orientation d'europe
il est là change la pile j'ai pas de
piles bas mais qu on est foutu [ __ ]
c'est pas cette pièce celle d'à côté
âgée pas de piles non mais c'est la mrda
c'est celui-là c'est encore à côté j'ai
pu voir deux films ex est chaud il nous
faudrait une pile s'il vous plaît allô
allô
dieu merci tu es vivant tu dois rester
calme
nous allons aider nous allons te sortir
de là tu dois trouver un endroit où de
cacher un endroit sûr où tu pourras te
rappeler le goût de son baiser quand tu
as senti son coût se brise espèces tant
que les tarés
ouais
ok on part là dessus ça marche
bon quoi s'est passé quoi encore
je me casse
oui oui je sais tu es parti à quelqu'un
c'est ok avec toi on est bien ok ok ok
ok dans une maison à dean ferry peur
aspera très bien et c'est pas une pile
de tarascon derrière depuis mizar parmi
d'autres sujets que le rapid à morges
fait confiance pour ne pas tuer ceux qui
ont été touchés féminin alors [ __ ] de
bâtard bongo à wau voyez s'il l'est nous
empêche te plaît deux secondes deux
secondes j'ai besoin qu'il soit soit là
il est au hockey comme devant avec
n'diaye avant par la parlent pas cher la
pile vite fait à mon avis pas parlé à
mon avis c'est de là d'où il vient comme
à chaque fois qu'on jouait ce [ __ ] de
jeu
[Applaudissements]
ça celle là c'est la donne est sorti à
la maison mme amos a lyon vers où tout
on verrouille tout
[Applaudissements]
un autre bandage [ __ ] on refait le
plein en plus c'est très cool encore une
pile [ __ ] mais qu on a fait un plein
on est hyper bien on est archi bien
juste la traque son père c'est pas aussi
part au spar spar abbas karben la
lumière soit à bastad
laisse moi te laisse moi te laissent
monter a été flèche mongay il se prend
pour un roux le mec
yes jdd des visites à maintenant c'est
bon c'est bon sens c'est bon c'est bon
ça ne nous aura pas hors de portée
je me soigne tranquillement le long de
la falaise
finalement c'est le meilleur endroit
pour se soigner mon gars [ __ ] ok on va
devoir se retaper l'arbre aux abeilles
c'est ça l'arbre aux abeilles qu'est la
wii encore utile avait mec jouant tout
le monde avait pu filer maintenant on a
eu quatre piles je crois incroyable et
basse pas loin de tomber
honnêtement je ne déteste [ __ ] hockey
à l'est de la ligne droite et chant que
c'est bientôt la farouche inouïe nous
mêler des flèches de transpac monga un
patin mais c'est pas possible il faut le
bandage
c'est quoi ça yes papa [ __ ] mais c'est
pas vrai la le montre par là
allez on y va au monument aux morts où
je leur demande pas de toit en toit et
un truc qui me suit j'entends des bruits
je ne préfère pas regarder a atteint
mais c'est pas vrai il vise trop bien
quoi le cas il aurait dû par rejoindre
set c'était la carrière dans le dans le
flash games
allez met un petit montage aller merde
je peux pas mettre de bandages bloqué
alors on va par la thématique si [ __ ]
mais non mais attends tu vomis coutu et
cordiale je bats l'ombre et comment il a
fait mais bon allez on continue ainsi
soit il
on y va [ __ ] de cactus qu on en est là
dans le class 2 go les émissaires des
cactus 6 un peu simple quand ça va pas
c'est gratuit
entretien tout va bien
entretien pourquoi je sais des bassins
l'évangile n'est pas encore terminée
bien entendu pour être aussi
enregistrera deux ans
attendu
l'élu
mauvaise idée a eu le mental air sais
pas qui je suis quand je vais sortir ici
je vais vous tuer non mais vraiment mais
non mais comment la vie au revoir ligne
au revoir avant tout le monde
ok eh ben les amis saisi à la fin de ce
3 quatrième épisode oh là là j'ai failli
faire impardonnable n'hésitez pas à
aller mais ça vous a plu à priori doit
nous rester encore trois épisodes à
faire environ donc ça se terminerait en
début de semaine prochaine bah voila
j'ai hâte de voir la fin du jeu j'ai un
devoir qui sont ces gens qui ont sauvé
line dans les mines
allez merci à vous regarder à bientôt
une prochaine vidéo au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]